foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and open the doors
hello hello welcome everybody to daily
with Doc my name is Becca dukes and I am
excited and honored Monday through
Friday to be able to host this program
and bring to you empowering information
that allows you as an individual to take
control of your own health
how about that do you like empowerment
or do you like to be controlled by
somebody else I personally
found that empowerment was much more
beneficial for my health which is why I
do what I do because of the benefits
that I was able to experience through
the teachings the knowledge and the
formulations that the good doctor that
we have on with us here on daily with
Doc provided to me over seven years ago
so if you are here live with us welcome
welcome to daily with Doc if you are out
on YouTube or Rumble hello Big Jim hello
Spartacus
we just welcome you all and you're also
you're welcome no matter where you're at
you're welcome to join us here on daily
with
doczoom.com that is how you get to the
live presentation that we are hosting
again Monday through Friday
that is from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific
time
so if you're in Eastern time just minus
or add three hours if you're in Central
Time add two hours if you're in Mountain
Time add one hour if you are in South
Africa add nine hours
okay
so I love the fact that we can reach
around the world with our program and
give people hope
that they do not have to be dependent on
an Institute that is failing them
and
folks were not chemical deficient
we are mineral deficient at least I was
and whenever I realized that and decided
to give the doctor 90 days
it didn't take 90 days for me to start
feeling like a whole new person
and I invite you to do the same now we
do want to
make sure that if you are here with us
this program is
sponsored by dailywitdoc.com we are a
group of independent Distributors who
have found without a doubt youngevity to
be the solution to filling those gaps
when it comes to nutritional
deficiencies because when nutritional
deficiencies occur the findings of Dr
Wallach have
never failed
when the deficiencies are there disease
is growing
the higher the deficiencies the more
just dis ease the more conditions the
more symptoms that you have that
really are not benefiting you and we
want to make sure that everybody is
living to their optimal best
that doesn't mean perfect sometimes
damage is done where all we can do is
live to our optimal best now the content
of this program is not to take the place
of your primary care physician
our products do not diagnose cure treat
any diseases
but when you give the body what it needs
folks the body can do some amazing
amazing things and our food supplies
around the world they're empty and void
of the nutrition that we actually need
they're helping us to survive
some cases not very well but when you
give the body what it needs it has the
opportunity to actually thrive
and that's one thing that the science of
epigenetics has proven
that one there is
there are no genetic birth defects
yes things can happen within the womb
because of deficiencies that then you
have a birth defect
but if there's no deficiencies in mama
before she gets pregnant and during
pregnancy
babies are going to be healthier
there's no guarantee in life but folks
when we do our part
there's a lot that we can do that
contributes or takes away from our
ability
to thrive
again welcome to daily with Doc if
somebody invited you make sure that you
get back with them and tell them thank
you for sharing this information with
you we are a resource to many and we
want to make sure that we support the
community and make this a safe place so
we
you know the folks within our community
are amazing
amazing people amazing coaches that have
a heart for people
so let's just make sure that if you were
shared this program by anybody specific
that you get back with them and tell
them thank you
thank you for taking the time and
sharing with
me
stop recording in progress
and yes we are now recording thank you
Ruth Ellen
um and just
thank them for caring enough
because if it wasn't for somebody
sharing this
with me I would have never found it
and I am so thankful for that
so without further ado
I am honored to welcome Dr Joel Wallach
a lifetime learner he has a bachelor's
degree in science in agriculture
agriculture
he has a doctor of veterinary medicine
he has three post doctorates in
pathology
and he has gone on to become a
naturopathic physician that is licensed
in multiple States across the United
States
He consults with people around the world
because folks
nutrition is needed around the world
so Dr Wallach
thank you so much for joining us here
today just like you do every Monday
through Friday
what do you have to share with us today
oh well thank you so much for the very
kind uh introduction and telling the
story which is I think useful to
everybody we do want to
start off by telling the loss of a good
friend uh Harry Belafonte passed today
uh 94 years of age
and um very famous during my time back
in the 1950s he was about to tell a
million albums 96 stock oh 96 okay he
was the first one to sell a million
albums very famous guy and he died of
something that was a simple nutritional
deficiency I wish I'd have known that he
had the problem we'd have contacted him
and sent him the stuff
but he died of congested heart failure
which is a simple nutritional deficiency
disease
and the odds are we could have at least
added a lot of time to when we if that
was a correct diagnosis we probably
could have just reversed it in a week or
10 days very simple disease to prevent
and reverse
um congestive heart failure but that's
what Harry died from so we'll send him
our prayers and our blessings I'm a
great guy great Entertainer
did a lot of great stuff for the heart
of America
then today
um
we want to talk about
babies and how to prevent birth defects
uh you know we did Rebecca and I did a a
interview earlier this morning
with a um some people who ladies who are
midwives and that sort of stuff where
they deal
with birthing and so forth
and so it's really I think we're going
to wind up getting a nice tool out of it
because we had a nice interview I was
thinking that was being recorded which
is a good thing
we have to appreciate that um contrary
to popular belief if you want to
eliminate any possibility of emergency
effects in your family remember there
are no diseases
there are no autoimmune diseases
and all birth defects
I'd say no no maybe 99 or caused by
nutritional efficiencies of the embryo
maybe one or two percent is caused by
poisons and I
feel alcohol syndrome and that kind of
stuff okay
so let's talk about what we can do here
well what we need to do if you're
talking about preventing all these birds
effects everyone you can name
okay many of them are we already know
that we can get rid of them and prevent
them and even cure them after the baby's
born mustard is physical brosis
those kinds of things
um
the
um sentiment death syndrome when they
die from that we can't bring them back
but they're certainly preventable simple
nutritional deficiencies
and it's one of those things where
um
cleft palate spina bifida those require
surgery after the baby's born but
they're totally preventable they're
nutritional deficiencies so when when is
the point at which you have to start
preventing these things well if you want
to prevent these diseases in your
grandkids your great grandkids your
great great grandkids you got to start
10 years ago okay okay because you have
to train people to stay away from all
the bad stuff no fried fusional process
Meats no oils or glutens or wheat to
burn around oats no sugar no carbonator
drinks even the diet one's got to go and
carbonated water got to go because they
neutralize stomach acids so you cannot
absorb minerals and digest food
and then you have to supplement with all
90 essential nutrients if you plan on
having babies really don't plan on
having babies but you know you're you
your kids are like
what newborn or not quite yet into
preschool or something like that you
better get them on the 90 essential
nutrients
get them on the 90 cents of nutrients
okay we're talking about kids tiny
we're talking about the 90th Century
nutrients healthy um Bone and Joint pack
which I'll rebound that kind of stuff
um you need to get them on the I-26 and
so forth get them on everything you can
okay as early as you can and never take
them off
because then they'll be in good shape
male or female when the sperm fertilizes
the egg
that that embryo is going to get
everything that needs to be perfect
and then after the baby's born
the baby needs to be put on these things
that the mother was on during you know
her prenatal and pregnancy
time then the baby's got it you know
even if he's being breastfed by the
mother he's still he or she needs to
still be on the 90th Century nutrients
for their life and the life of their
offspring the life of their offspring
the life of their offspring you can't
say well I've missed three Cycles when
do I start taking some prenatal vitamins
well there's three Cycles too late the
odds are there's gonna be some problems
there okay and so you have to be
thinking ahead general for Generations
to prevent all these birth defects oh
yeah you know we took all this stuff and
baby stillborn
with cleft palettes baby stillborn but
with um spina bifida now the baby was
stillborn with
um
mushroom District all those kind of
things well we spent a lot of money
um suing the FDA in federal court
to put all these nutrients into baby
formula so as soon as that baby is born
and the baby's on baby Farmers they're
going to get these nutrients and prevent
a lot of that stuff or reverse a lot of
that stuff
but wouldn't it be better if
the mother to be
okay
when say a year or two or five or six or
ten before she was conceived
if the mother started taking all these
vitamins and minerals and stay away from
the bad foods so when the babies come
along
they're protected against the injury
from the bad foods and they're protected
and supported by all these nutrients
that the mother was taken in
and this is the way we have to think now
this is why in livestock we don't worry
about birth defects
because
the cows and the mother Pigs and the
chickens and hens
um
and all of the animals we raise that way
in the zoos are being fed these
nutrients
okay long before they're going to get
pregnant
and that way The Offspring is 99.9 can
be good
and then
you've got to keep giving them all the
nutrients and so their offspring will be
perfect give them all the nutrients so
their offspring would be perfect that's
what we have to think it's kind of like
you don't wait until you've got 5 000
miles in your car
to put oil in it
before you drive that car out of the
when you buy a new car or used car
before you drive it off
the dealership's property you check the
oil
I don't take their word for it I check
the oil I check the radiator I check the
brake fluid I check the transmission
fluid okay I checked there in the tires
I want to make sure everything is
perfect
before I take possession of it okay and
that's what you have to think in terms
of your family yourself and your kids to
be your grandkids to be in your great
grandkids and so forth and then there
won't be any more burst effects that's
why we don't have to have health
insurance
for farm animals
and we have life insurance for expensive
resources
we don't have health insurance for cows
and pigs and chickens and things like
that okay it's much cheaper just to give
them all the nutrients and prevent all
the diseases
and then we don't have to have the
veterinarian or veterinary technician to
come out to the farm every week to treat
these animals and test these animals for
diseases and so forth because we're
preventing them
okay and that's where we need to think
in terms of ourselves
now it's it's and you say well that's
going to cost me a couple hundred bucks
a month because I got several kids okay
well guess what how much is it going to
cost you if each one of those kids has a
baby with a birth defect
okay even if it's not a birth defect
that you can do something about
with surgery or something like that
the emotional misery that you're
preventing by preventing those birth
defects of the parents the grandparents
aunts and uncles because they go and
talk to their doctors the doctors tell
them oh it's a genetic thing they're all
screwed up in the head because the
doctor tells them it's a genetic thing
and so they're all worried about that
this is not difficult and so
you have to say okay
do I want to really get crazy here my
whole family be beat down because a baby
in her family is born with a bird's
effect that it could prevent it for a
couple bucks a day
it's cheaper
to prevent birth defects than it is to
buy Starbucks coffee
it's cheaper
okay so it's not like you're spending a
thousand bucks a day to prevent birth
defects
okay this is actually quite simple
and so and quite economical and so I
urge you to think in those terms and you
will and your family will the community
will
and our country will and the world will
be benefited by this line of thinking
okay and so uh see you were there kind
of making sure that everything went
right technologically Rebecca and so do
you think we got the message across
I think we did Dr well like and the
thing that I love about it is this group
of of individuals that were in this
meeting that we were in this morning
they they were doulas they were midwives
they were people that want to do things
closer to
nature the way things were designed and
that's exactly Dr Wallach what your
formulas kind of have the a nice little
marriage
too they fit perfectly in
and
from my experience okay I've had four
pregnancies
all four of them were very difficult I
was on bed rest from five months on and
then each of them were born either five
four three five weeks early
because my body just wasn't gonna have
it
and if I would have had your nutrients
Dr Wallach
I'm 99.9 positive
that it would have been different
oh yeah everything else that would have
been different
is I I wouldn't have children that have
dyslexia or learning disabilities
now I support them to be the absolutely
best that they possibly can
but I was looking at something this
morning
and in the last 30 years
ADHD has increased that's hyper
um
HD ADHD
it's increased over 800 percent
autism has increased over 2 000 percent
bipolar disease in youth
over ten thousand percent just in the
last 30 years this is the increase Dr
Wallach
are these things
nutritional deficiencies yes and I I
like our theme in America bring me your
bring me your poor and bring me your
sick and so forth and we can fix all
that we can fix all that and we can
prevent all that and so it's a matter of
you okay you you have gone to doctors
forever and doctors have given up
misinformation that they were taught in
school
and so it's time
to say okay you know I'm going to
continue having my doctor like my doctor
nothing wrong with that but I'm going to
add two
okay because I learned something here
that's going to benefit my family
benefit my community benefit me my
benefit of my community in in the
Greater Community in the world okay by
doing the things I know that need to be
done uh don't just depend on insurance
for a doctor to buy some prescription to
help you with a kid with autism okay we
need to give them nutrition we need to
get rid of the bad stuff
and we need to educate that child okay
so they know not to get steered Off The
Track by you know their school and
they're going to go have
um some secret waffles or pancakes or or
that kind of stuff with their buddies
and you can't figure out why they're not
responding properly that's because
they're eating gluten no game because
they don't know nobody's told them
well
and there there's something to that Dr
Wallach I homeschool my son
when he's not with me
he does not have the control diet that
he has and his tutor is like Becca he's
like night and day difference when it
comes to his ability to focus
and and be
with me
when we're working on stuff
and then you can see it physically also
so there's really something to this
folks when it comes to taking that
gluten out of the diet and removing that
hindrance it's a barrier to absorption
of nutrients
so
you may not think that you have
nutritional deficiencies you may not
think that you have any issue with wheat
barley right or oats or buckwheat
I didn't think that I did but then when
I took it out of my diet all of these
things that I was experiencing
just started fading away because I did
that once I was on the nutrition and I
was getting better absorption of the
nutrition that I was investing in for my
own health and Becca what do you do for
somebody who just loves spaghetti they
can't live without spaghetti what would
you do for them
there's gluten-free spaghetti dog yeah
yeah that's funny because somebody over
here said Canada
um but
yeah so there's there's gluten-free
options everywhere and then making sure
that you're keep taking
foreign
these kids need to be taught this so
that if you're not around either for a
day or a week or a month or you know
when time comes you pass on and they're
40 50 years old and they're reverting
back and starting to eat gluten again
because you're not there to control them
anymore and then they wonder why they're
all screwed up and they have heart
disease and have kidney stuff and high
blood pressure and diabetes and
Alzheimer's disease all my doctor says
it's all genetic and they just buy into
them and so they need to be taught every
minute of every hour of every day of
every month of every year for the rest
of your life and
um you reward them when they do the
right thing and they get punished when
they do the wrong thing they do the
wrong thing you say okay no dessert for
you tonight because you were bad you
were drinking that Cola okay well
there's no gluten in Cola no but there
is carbonation
Dr Wallach
I'm sorry
but I'm I'm good I'm gonna disagree with
you a little bit here oh because when
you tell somebody and you punish
somebody
for doing something they're going to
want to do it more but I think when you
educate somebody as to why you're making
these recommendations
why you've adopted these habits
and pointing out okay this is what has
happened whenever these things when we
were eating these things
and now that we're not eating these
things we don't have to deal with the
anger issues the mood swings all of
those things so I think educating as to
why we do things rather than just say
don't don't don't don't and you can't
have that because you did this I know
with some of my kids that didn't work
but some kids that does work
so I think the education part Dr Wallach
which is why we do this program is
essential and healthy people to
understand why you're making the
recommendations that you're making
and when you're educated and understand
it's so much easier to accept yeah have
you ever heard of the term survival of
the fittest
I have heard the term survival of the
finished yes does that include mental
All the Above All the Above and so this
is one of those things where
um
you really have to pay attention to
what's going on around you you have to
pay attention on to what you're doing
you have to pay attention to what people
who are living with you are doing
because they can cross-contaminate you
in the laundry and on the couch on the
kitchen table and you know
on the dishwasher and everything like
that and so
um everything has to be kind of watched
um and he said why am I why is this
happening am I eating egg gluten but
then maybe everybody else your family is
and you're washing your clothes and
washer and dryer at the same time they
are
um sitting on the couch and wondering
they're covered in
in the dust from crackers and cookies
and everything made out of wheat
yeah
well there's a lot there's a lot to it
Dr Wallach
um and and I'm learning more and more
each and every day
and we had mentioned some of the
conditions that have increased you know
with childhood and it's a attention
hyperactivity
yeah
the I-26 in chewables okay we also have
synaptive we also have the healthy
branded heart pack we have the kids
toddy we have the plant minerals and
I need to start collecting
all these wonderful events that take
place when we have people who can't
they're unconscious certain Comas and
whatever and we're just rubbing the
minerals on them we're having all these
miraculous turnarounds uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna put together about 20 or 30 of
these into one presentation
and um just to show just putting the
minerals on you and absorbing them it's
almost like intravenous okay yeah yeah
take the minerals you didn't like the
minerals I mean come on who doesn't like
Cherry memes who doesn't like rebounds
you know you'd stop it well they think
when they're talking about not liking
the minerals Dr well like eat
the plain plant Drive minerals they have
a pucker factor to them it's like
you know
um so
they're easy to mix with other things
and make amazing mineral rich
drinks
super simple
but
it's yeah it's everybody can come up
with an excuse for anything and
everything
but folks when you're focusing on the
solution not the problem with something
it makes it so much easier
now I mentioned the increase Dr Wallach
in some of the childhood conditions over
the last 30 years
but chronic fatigue syndrome for Mom and
Dad
um depression
fibromyalgia
hypothyroidism lupus osteoarthritis all
of these things
I mean chronic fatigue syndrome has over
000 percent increase
in the last two years what has his
eleven thousand percent increase
chronic fatigue syndrome oh my gosh
so people are just they're doing more
and more and more and they're
taxing their body and sucking all those
nutrients out of their bodies and not
feeling them
and they're leading it's leading to
chronic fatigue syndrome
and then depression
another thing you know
lupus so lupus Dr Wallach is over 700
increase and I know that you've
mentioned many times about
um buckwheat
so I'm a farm kid
we did not want our horses getting into
any buckwheat
because of those phagopyrenes in the
plant itself it's a chemical that burns
the skin
I mean you would have a light colored
horse and you could really really see it
the inflammation the blisters
the breakout all around their mouth on
their nose the same thing to the
intestines
and that's exactly where I was going Dr
Wallach if they're experiencing that as
a horse a very large animal
and then we're taking a product of that
same plant
how can there not be any
cross-contamination from the aerial to
the seed and then we're putting it in
our bodies
and it's wreaking havoc on our
intestines on our digestive system
yet it's gluten-free
just say no
you've got to look at the whole picture
Dr Wallach
I mean we can look at a small little
piece of anything and everything
and take only the good and forget the
bad well it's not bad that's affecting
us
we want to focus on the solutions so why
not look at the big picture
and move forward
right you get an A plus plus
all right well let's see if we can help
some people today Dr Wallach let's go
for it but folks if you're here live
with us and you would like to ask Dr
Wallach a question please feel free to
raise your hand go to that Zoom menu and
look for Ray's hand under the reactions
because we want to make sure that we are
getting the questions that meet people
where they're at if you're out there in
uh YouTube or Rumble land you can go
ahead and ask your questions there and
we've got people from New Mexico New
Jersey from Canada from
lots of places up here I can't scroll
through it all
um but we want to make sure that we get
you our questions answered as well now
we do have questions that are coming in
through uh people signing up for our
newsletter so folks go to
dailywooddoc.com and we have a
newsletter there that you can sign up
for we also have an option there as you
sign up if you have a question for Dr
Wallach that you would like to get an
answer for I pick a lot of them or when
I can I pick them so that we can answer
them here live on daily with Doc we
don't get to your question I do have a
team of certified holistic health
coaches that are helping me go through
them many many I mean we're talking
hundreds of questions that are coming in
so if you've submitted one rest assured
we will get to you and get an answer for
you as well through the email that you
supplied so if the email address that
you supplied is not correct sorry books
you're not going to get an answer
Dr Wallach yes
so we have a young man
um in his early 50s
six foot
225 pounds
who is experiencing fatigue
joint issues
burning sensation in his testicles he's
got heart stress he's looking for weight
loss
he has a burning sensation also in his
rectum also athlete's foot
hair loss and he thinks that's it
but he's got a lot of stuff going on Dr
Wallach
I know many of them are nutrient
deficiencies
what would you recommend for this
individual okay well first of all
nothing he has is genetic
another thing he has is autoimmune
so we'll start with that platform okay
so there's hope for him right oh
absolutely and so there's two things
this guy needs to do number one get rid
of all the bad stuff he's spent his life
when you say he's old
um he's in his mid-50s it just says mid
50s mid 50s okay so he spends 52 and a
half years okay or 55 years
doing all the bad stuff
fried foods processed meats and we're
talking about ham and bacon and bologna
and salami and hot dogs and pepperoni
and all that kind of stuff and also
he's been using lots of salad dressings
and cooking oils eating lots of gluten
wheat Brown around oats and there's lots
of Faygo pyrenes in the buckwheat
um the sugar carbonated drinks even the
diet drinks have carbonation in them and
also carbonated water a lot of people do
that oh I use a carbonated water I don't
drink the you know the sugar and stuff
in the caffeine I just drink the
carbonated water and while the
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot
um
absorb minerals and digest food you need
stomach acid to do that that's what the
good lord gave us the cells in our
stomach to make stomach gas and we
require salt sodium chloride uh every
day two three times a day to make sure
that we're getting our stomach acid made
because our stomach acid is made from
sodium chloride okay
and
then at 200 pounds and he's how tall
five
a six foot six foot and he's 200
something pounds I don't know why I'd
want to lose weight unless it's all in
his belly okay but anyway get rid of all
the bad stuff okay then he also needs to
take two healthy brain and heart packs
for months two Health abandoned heart
pressure 215 nutrients in each of the
healthy brain and hard packs and take a
photo showing twice a day get two
bottles a month of the MSM so you take
three at breakfast three lunch three
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
Rich bonus cell heart valves
um bone marrow and all that kind of
stuff the immune system it also needs
the collagen peptides to take to two
canisters a month so you take a scoop of
this morning drink to his evening drink
it's a collagen from fish and poultry
and sheep and beef and then also needs
synaptive takes three of those twice a
day as two vowels a month that's going
to help his brain cells and and spinal
cord cells to talk to each other he also
needs the I-26 to help rebuild his
myelin the white matter of the brain his
spinal cord
so that he's not having any kind of
short circuiting on signals from his
brain okay to the other part of the
brain and sales from the brain of the
spinal cord and sales from the spinal
cord of the body and so on and he's at
I-26 I take two of those a day I like
the chewables they taste like vanilla
ice cream
um and
they're about the diameter of a quarter
and about a half a millimeter
thick very tasty little kids like them
and then uh he should be eating three
eggs twice a day well my doctor says it
can't have AIDS because all the
cholesterol well get change doctors
because cholesterol you require
cholesterol cholesterol makes up 25 of
the normal brain weight is called myelin
the white matter of the brain
cholesterol except 25 percent of your
spinal cord weight it's called myelin
makes up 25 percent of your spinal cord
weight any Doctor Who says to get off of
eggs
should have their licenses taken away
and they should be put in jail okay
um because cholesterol is an essential
nutrient we actually say on the label of
our I-26
each dose we have the powder we have the
tablets and we have the tubals each
serving gives you 25 of your daily
needed cholesterol you need cholesterol
so it's as important as oxygen and water
okay and then let's see here what else
did this guy have
um what did I miss here
okay well let's talk about the fungus he
can take our colloidal silver uh
topically wherever he has can you know
an open wound uh between his toes that
kind of stuff he could use her colloidal
silver he can take two droppers full of
collateral silver under his tongue but
say Tim is for breakfast lunch and
dinner
it kills viruses uh bacteria fungus and
yeast uh he also needs to take our hair
skin and nails for the hair and the skin
issues I wanted to take three of those
three times a day that'll be three
bottles a month because they're just
small little bottles or Hair Skin and
nails
and let's see here I think that covers
what we do want to have for energy we
wanted to take our rebound
um the sticks don't have any carbonation
in them there's 30 sticks in a box okay
we have the canister there's 36 servings
in the canister it's a powder also
there's a hundred nutrients in each
serving here there's 100 nutrients in
determining here we do have the cans
but the cans do have carbonation them so
I like to pop the tops and put them in
the refrigerator in the afternoon or the
evening so the next day they're flat all
the bubbly is gone and I'll have one for
breakfast and I'll have half one for
lunch I'll have the rest that second
half of the second one over the
afternoon okay and get it all done
before four o'clock so it won't keep me
up all night and so that's where I would
have this guys start did I miss anything
no but I want to point out thyroid did
he have a thyroid issue did this guy
have a thyroid I didn't see any that
thyroid issue but I wanted to point out
because you had mentioned about the
plant dry minerals putting them on the
skin anything that you put on the skin
is going to absorb into the skin through
the skin into the bloodstream so even if
you take that colloidal silver put it in
a little spray bottle which makes it
easier for dispensing rather than the
droppers and spray it on the areas that
you're experiencing the itching the
inflammation the irritation the
infection
it's going to be beneficial
so I have questions
but there's no alcohol yeah I have the
colloidal silver and the droppers
um I when I went on my little vacation I
got a little bit of an allergy irritant
and my eye did a couple drops within a
couple hours I had no more irritation or
anything going on with my eyes which was
was fantastic because that would have
ruined my vacation
but you can do it on any area of the
body and spray that on there whether
you've got an open wound or it's just
inflamed
um
it's it's just it's easy just like the
plant Drive minerals I've got a bigger
spray bottle for the plant right now I'd
throw one more thing at this guy
test
it's a male hormone test
is there a test
okay is there a test
I got the right one for the guy right
zero two yes he was having some burning
sensation in his testicles so could that
be for um something that those are
tested yeah more hormone production
uh-huh or male hormone production and of
course the itching kind of stuff that
can be due to you know lack of collagen
and so forth and so that's where the
um that's for the uh collagen comes from
okay that's where you you need the
um MSM you need the collagen peptides
and so forth and they'll take care of
all that
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and we've got some
questions here that are coming in in the
chat and
Sharon has a client she's a female 50
years old
five foot four inches
172 pounds
she has gum issues on both sides the
left side bottom jaw is swollen
inflammation in the top back shoulder
so
it doesn't say and Sharon if you can put
in the comments um is she experiencing
anything else like blood sugar issues
blood pressure issues that would be
helpful also ringing in the ears
um
balance problems always wake up at night
to urinate
there you go so Sharon if you can add
those things in there that would be very
beneficial please but to get started
let's get off all the bad stuff in case
you can get a Dodge rolling cooking
without the bad foods 300 pages of safe
recipes
um also contains a good food bad food
list also good cooking safe cooking
methods back to watch cooking without
the bad foods and then
um let's see here none of the batteries
no fried food process means no oil for
gluten and we barrier I know so sugar no
carbon or drinks and then
um her weight 170 pounds 172 pounds 172.
okay yep needs a two healthy branded
heart pasture months two full doses a
day so he's two bottles a month so the
MSM think take three breakfast right
lunch through dinner time it also needs
two canisters a month of the collagen
peptides you can take a few of their
morning drinks through the evening drink
I also wanted to have the synaptives so
her brain cells can talk to each other
okay three eggs twice today with soft
yolks not hard boiled not fried
and let's see here so she does have
blood pressure issues Dr Wallach no two
blood sugar issues and yes she wakes up
oh no to blood pressure issues but yes
she does wake up to urinate
several times during the night okay so
she can osteoporosis disco yep
um and then she needs the um let's see
here what else do we need to throw in
there vitamin D3 through those twice a
day we said synaptive oh for the blood
pressure she needs the ultimate daily
classic has three words ultimate daily
classic ultimate daily classic uh take
three of those twice a day there's two
bottles a month
and uh that will if she's on blood
pressure medication don't cold turkey
off the medication but as the blood
pressure begins to come down she can
slowly reduce the medication based on
the numbers usually you know you know
you can expect some miraculous results
within two to four weeks and obviously
give us 90 days and usually they're
totally off of their blood pressure
medication within 90 days I just had
another case in Florida where they're
really in a disastrous position and uh
very bad and um
hospitalized near death many times we
got him going on a similar program and
in two weeks time
everything's fine but they said well how
long do we have to stay on this well how
long do you need oxygen forever how long
do you need water forever how long you
need the 90 cents of nutrients forever
how long you need all these nutrients
forever okay otherwise within a couple
of months we back down to the hole again
you might not get out of the hole the
second time okay right
well here's one for you Dr Wallach and
folks if you're hearing any information
on this program that it is triggering
some thoughts for you it's like okay I
know somebody that has that I know
somebody that has that they would
benefit from what Dr Wallach is sharing
make sure that you get back with the
person that invited you to this program
if there's nobody to think go to
dailywithdoc.com use that contact us and
I will get you in touch with one of our
certified holistic health coaches who
strictly use Dr wallach's protocols
his products were the only solution that
I found
with all of my issues that I was
experiencing they're the only ones that
I recommend and that's what we train our
coaches
in in the same way and if we have any
questions if we don't know the answers
to we have access to Dr Wallach right
here
um and we'll make sure that you get the
information that he would provide to you
as well
coach Rod has a male cousin Dr Wallach
only 33 years old
98 pounds
five foot four
he has a non-cancerous brain tumor
um it has caused him to lose sight in
one eye
the doctors say that they can't operate
but they do want to do radiation
he has no appetite
and they're wanting to know what can be
done to help stop the growth of this
tumor
okay well first of all need to get rid
of all the bad foods you know eat like
an Asian rice and beans and squash and
sweet potatoes and vegetables and you
can have fish and poultry and beef and
stuff like that right
um no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils or gluten so we burn around oats no
sugar no carbonated drinks
um then I wanted to have uh let's see
here
uh I wanted to have
three eggs twice a day
three eggs twice over soft yolks soft
boiled salt pots soft soft smell and
butter
um I had three soft Poached Eggs this
morning for breakfast I mean I do this
all the time he needs the I-26 on to
have three servings a day the I-26 we
have the pills the powder and the
chewables I like the jewels I take two
of the chills at lunch and he needs to
take two chewables three times a day or
two pills three times a day or three
doses of powder three times a day the
I-26 to rebuild that brain
um
you can see here
also
needs the
MSM
two bottles of evidence I'm sorry take
three of breakfast here lunch at dinner
time they're gonna help me rebuild the
current Leisure ligaments tenons
connective tissue disk between a
vertebrae bone makes bone itself
including the skull
and the jaw and so forth needs to have
um
I would go ahead with the collagen
peptides go ahead and take a scuba those
morning drinks you'll be eating drink
that's two canisters a month he needs to
be synaptic two bottles of that a month
so you can take three of breakfast or
dinner times the brain cells and spinal
cord cells can all talk to each other
um let's see here he needs a rebound or
as far as drinking can have
um I start out with one a day because he
only weighs 100 pounds or so kind of
like that so I'd have him take a half a
dose yeah whether it's the powder
um the sticks are the can so he's gonna
drink the cans remember he's got to pull
the tops on them and put them in the
refrigerator don't drink them until the
next day but he can take a half a dose
of a rebound of breakfast that is
carbonated free and then half a dose the
other half at lunch time
and um what did I miss
well I'm going to recommend Dr Wallach
the fucoid Z
and see he doesn't have an appetite so
I'm also going to recommend our total
meal replacement shake
um
it's tasty it'll give him his nutrition
even though he's doesn't want to eat
it'll still give him something that he
can drink
um you can mix in some of these other
things that Dr Wallach is recommending
as well into that to make sure that he's
making the most of what he is getting in
his body with nutrition
so that's one of the recommendations
and something that's not from the
youngevity line
I know you thought I was gonna say
something I'm going to recommend staying
away from any and all diet drinks
the sweeteners that are added to those
diet drinks have been proven to be
um hazardous to People's Health whether
cancer tumors or not
um
I have two family members uh three
family members who were very much into
drinking diet sodas and brain tumors
were
found in each of them so that might be
that might be something that's playing a
factor into this
so
I think that's it so coach Rod if you
have any additional questions
um feel free to ask because we are here
for you
and we have
we have just a few more minutes Dr
Wallach I have a question coming in on
email in regards to fasting
so Dennis wants to know
where he's saying I'm considering a
three-day water fast
with sodium potassium
and
sodium so he says there are three
elements mentioned to help during the
process he says I use the essential 90
daily should I continue to use this
since it has no sugars or fats
so I'm
water has no nutrition in it
if you're adding two elements to it
which sodium potassium and then sodium
that's still only two
your body needs nutrition
so he can still take his 90 essential
nutrients right even if he's doing a
water fast absolutely now usually when
people are doing a water fast they want
to detox they want to it's a faithful
slash religious thing okay and but no I
I want people to take the 90 essential
nutrients believe me
um in the old days in the days of the
Garden of Eden the land flowing with
milk and honey when they went on a fast
they were drinking that water
that look like milk wasn't milk it was
minerals coming from the mountains is
why it looked white okay
yeah that's that's an amazing story Dr
well I like to to think about that not
being land flung with milk and honey and
that milk not being milk with something
that looks like milk yes because
mineral Rich I've read the Bible many
times on many airplane many foreign
countries in many languages and nobody
ever talks about Dairy herd in the
Garden of Eden whether it's cows or
goats or whatever there's no there's no
Dairy herds there was no milk and so
where is that milk coming from okay the
milk was coming from the minerals up in
the mountains and that's why
um Methuselah would be 969 years of age
okay he's getting all those minerals and
all these his sons and uh Noah would be
I don't know 500 and something
um because they were getting these
minerals so the land flowing was
mineral milk and honey I'm gonna uh yeah
okay kind of add a little bit to that
um because I have one more question I
want to get in before you have to go
Okay Go Okay so Leighton has a daughter
that's 19 years old she has low HDL
cholesterol she has slight Tremors once
in a while she has seizures brain fog
and
times I'm not quite sure what how that
fits in
um
how could we address this she's four
foot 11 and 120 pounds at 19 years old
okay low cholesterol get rid of all the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
meat some oils no glutens no buckwheat
no sugar no oils absolutely no
um carbonated water then she does need a
hundred and something pounds
cut it in half half of those breakfast
half at those dinner time she needs one
bottle a month to the MSM she can take
three breakfasts free dinner time so she
maintained Carly's Lehman's tendons
connective tissue all that kind of stuff
skin
etc etc I also wanted her to have our
I-26 I wanted to have uh three doses a
day she can have the chewables she can
have the powders she can have the
capsules she can mix them up and have
the chubbles at lunch and powders at
breakfast and didn't cancel the dinner
however she wants to do it but three
doses okay of the I-26 a day I also
wanted to have a synaptive take three of
those twice a day there's two bottles a
month I also want her to have
um
let's see here I would ever have her
take the Z radical
liquid tastes very nice tastes kind of
like a mild red wine there's no alcohol
in it but it does have the nutrients
from seaweed eight or nine different
seaweeds in the ocean uh she prefers cat
food she could take the few coins Z
capsules take two or three of those
twice a day don't forget the ocean's
gold
okay and I want her to use also our
seasoned salt from Australia or
are Himalayan salt from the Himalayan
Mountains one or the other two doses of
our salt today
all right and
and the brain and heart pack has two
different
essential fatty acids in it yes you need
them both for brain and heart health
that's why they're alone yep
and lung yes it will prevent reverse
asthma
well they they are beneficial for a lot
doctor well like I have a whole list
that someday I'll go through this list
of the things that you found to be
related to essential fatty acids
so next time well Dr Wallach thank you
so much for joining us here with us on
daily with Doc we greatly appreciate you
your knowledge your research and your
time that you spend with us each and
every Monday through Friday
have a wonderful blessed day Dr Wallach
thank you thank you thank you bye for
now bye-bye
thank you
okay if I could get my co-host up with
me that would be fantastic folks you're
watching daily with Doc whether you're
here live with us whether you're
watching a replay you're out watching
one of our live streams we want to make
sure that you are getting the
information and support that you need
also if somebody shared this program
with you make sure that you get back
with them and thank them and ask them
questions say hey this is what I've got
going on do you know what Dr Wallach
would recommend for me
and if that coach doesn't know then make
sure that you tell them about daily with
Doc and let's get answers for you
because if you've got questions
I know without a shadow of doubt that
there are other people out there that
are going through some of the same
things that you're going through that
would benefit from your questions as
well we are here to help people find
Optimal Health to get out of that barely
surviving feeling way too young
or being way too young to feel this old
type situations
we are here to help people live long
abundant
full of life lives I just want to give a
shout out to my coaches that I have on
with me as co-hosts helping to make this
happen we have Farhan who's going
through and letting people in watching
the cameras we have Marilyn who's
putting lots of information in the chat
so that's that's one of the benefits of
being here will live with us is you can
open up that chat and Marilyn is taking
the situation and writing in Dr
wallach's recommendations for people to
be able to see
we have sherry Browning who is helping
keep an eye on all of the cameras and
the chat and taking screenshots and
sending them to me just so that I don't
miss anything that's going on in that
chat that needs to be seen and Ruth
Ellen doing all the above and making
sure that we're streaming where we're
supposed to be streaming and we have
sound where we're supposed to have sound
we appreciate you all we have sportus
that's out in YouTube land keeping a
track of all of the posts that are going
on out there we greatly
greatly appreciate all of you taking the
time
you are worth the investment of time and
the investment that it takes to nutriate
your body so that you also can have the
possibility of living an optimal life
so get back with a person
oh and then we have kitty
not quite sure what what the name is but
yeah we've got our Fur Pets too they are
family
have a wonderful and blessed day and we
will see you again tomorrow
my name is Becca Dukes daily withdoc.com
make sure that you get signed up with
and for our newsletter
and if you have questions again you can
submit them there if you have never
spoken to anybody about youngevity and
you would like to speak with a certified
holistic health coach if you've never
tried any of the products we do have a
call team that's standing by eight five
five
nine four nine three three seven seven
that's eight five five
again that's for people that have never
spoken to anybody no associate nobody
referred you to this program
about youngevity so if you're part of
our newsletter if you have heard us on
Coast to coach which I want to do a
shout out for my buddy George Nori he
has Dr Wallach that he is hosting
tonight on the coast to coast Network
um from 10 to 12 p.m Pacific time so
thank you George for all that you do in
allowing us to be part of your team so
until next time
bye for now
record
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign